well the biggest misconception is that
science has ever settled i think the
public has that to their to their you
know to their dismay because believing
that science is settled is antithetical
to science think about it they if if
galileo came along and said well
aristotle was a scientist he's very
smart uh i'll just accept that there are
only four elements instead of you know
114 or that heavy things fall faster
than light things all these things he
could have verified by the way but he
didn't actually go out and do that but
galileo would never have come up with
the laws of initial laws of relativity
same with newton einstein because well
newton is a genius i can't outdo newton
as he often looked up to him so
therefore as richard feynman the great
nobel laureate of the 20th century said
science is the belief in the ignorance
of experts otherwise you'd have no
motivation to ever modify refine and
improve upon who or what came before you
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
distinguished professor of physics at
the center for astrophysics and space
sciences at uc san diego and author of
the new book into the impossible think
like a nobel prize winner brian keating
finally welcome to the reuben report
thank you dave you were my first big
guest on my podcast so it's nice to
return the favor i know you've been
looking forward to having a big guest
like me on for a while
i've wanted a man of science on for
quite some time and no i've wanted to
talk to you for a while on the show
because i think this will be a little
bit different than the shows that that
we normally do but framing one thing
sort of politically just to jump us off
as a man of science and as a man that
just wrote a book about how scientists
approach science
what do you make of the state of science
at the moment science is getting pretty
banged up these days
yeah it's it's tough you know i used to
say i enjoy being an astronomer because
there's no republican asteroids there's
no democratic comets uh there's no you
know it's apolitical but it's become
incredibly politicized as you point out
uh i always point out dave you know the
word science in latin i know you're a
scholar so you'll know this word science
means knowledge it doesn't mean wisdom
so to expect wisdom from people that are
knowledge you know junkies wikipedia has
a lot of knowledge doesn't have any
wisdom you wouldn't want to trust your
dog with it right so i i do believe that
we're living in a fundamentally uh
scientific technological age that kind
of is worshiping scientists
way more than i think we weren't uh as
anyone who's ever known uh the famous
joke about scientists how do you know a
scientist is outgoing because he looks
at your shoes when he talks to you
and uh you know it's it's part of the
goal of this book is that is to humanize
scientists and to to you know recognize
that we're just human beings we have no
special you know truth claims or wisdom
claims than anyone else
does that sort of chasm between
knowledge and wisdom sort of capture
exactly the moment we're at in a way
where it's like we hear things every day
in the news okay there's a new study
that says something
that tells us something about knowledge
to some degree but then the wisdom of
the policies that then we are told we
have to follow often seems a little
screwy at least in my humble opinion
yeah looking again you know if you look
to somebody uh for wisdom when you know
again looking for to wikipedia for
wisdom is not going to be too fruitful
and yet we crave it because we worship
at the altar of science in some way
justifiably so it's led to life
you know increases
child mortality rates plummeting
vaccines and so forth that are just
miraculous and in any other way would be
difficult to describe it understanding
the composition evolution
of the universe you know to to a
fraction of a percent just astonishing
and yet
we don't as a laity as the lay person
don't really have a good understanding
of how science works so as the words of
arthur c clarke say any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic and some say it could be
indistinguishable from a god and so i
think there is a tendency a desire to
worship
at the altar of science and i think
that's misplaced because we don't elect
scientists uh as a population we elect
politicians a president uh governors etc
we elect those people and they want to
pass off i think some of their
responsibility the scientists who we
don't elect and we wouldn't elect in any
other capacity
so last part on this specifically but do
you sense that sort of the reputation
that science and scientists have gotten
over the last year where it's been so
sort of battered and inconsistent and
wear masks don't wear masks it's the vax
is working it's not working booster
shots the whole thing do you think it
can recover in the next couple years
because right now when they just trot
out the next study like at this point
i'm just like this is just just more
nonsense i'm not saying i don't believe
that the study was conducted but what it
will always lead to is just like i can't
listen to this stuff anymore well the
biggest misconception is that science
has ever settled i think the public has
that to their to their you know to their
dismay because believing that science is
settled is antithetical to science think
about it dave if if galileo came along
and said well aristotle was a scientist
he's very smart i'll just accept that
there are only four elements instead of
you know 114 or that heavy things fall
faster than light things all these
things he could have verified by the way
but he didn't actually go out and do
that but galileo would never have come
up with the laws of initial laws of
relativity same with newton einstein
because well newton is a genius i can't
outdo newton as he often looked up to
him so therefore as richard feynman the
great nobel laureate of the 20th century
said science is the belief in the
ignorance of experts otherwise you'd
have no motivation to ever modify refine
and improve upon who or what came before
you so i i view that uh and i view it to
the to the detriment of science and
scientists themselves you know often
people say i'm no einstein i can't
understand it well guess what dave
einstein wasn't einstein you know in the
beginning of his life so i think the
more that we kind of venerate without
explaining how science is actually done
it harms our own practitioners of the
craft of science that i i am engaged in
yeah and that really actually is what
the book is about because you talk about
things like creativity and human
expression and passion all of these
things that we don't really associate
with scientists and their work
specifically so let's just dive in so
you have nine chapters here each one
going off a different scientist for a
different reason i thought we could just
spend a couple minutes on everybody uh
but you got to leave some secrets here
otherwise people won't buy the book so a
couple minutes on everybody i know how
it works chapter one is about adam reese
the star gazer yeah so adam is a
contemporary of mine he's basically my
age and back in uh i think it was 2005
there was a worldwide competition to
determine uh who was the greatest you
know scientist under the age of 40 and
he and i entered it i came in first as
the most promising scientist of all time
at least of that age and then adam came
in third uh and so uh later you know six
years later when he won the nobel prize
my older brother kevin who watches the
show uh he called to report on me and
said brian you won the battle but adam
you you
you had the temporary reprieve so adam
is um is an incredibly curious uh
individual he's very young and what is
often said about the nobel prize in fact
by nobel laureate t.s eliot who won it
for literature he said the nobel is a
ticket to your own funeral because no
one ever does it after he wins it and
adam is a real counter example to that
canard because he has gone on to you
know great heights astronomically and
otherwise uh educational mentorship etc
i think he best exemplifies the fact
that you know dave i never thought i
could be a professional astronomer you
know growing up as we did on long island
uh you know i thought like oh someone's
gonna pay me to be an astronomer like
they're gonna pay me to be an ice cream
taster or you know or a wizard or
something like that so i really do look
at him as the fulfillment of this dream
that you can do it uh you can achieve
your your passion but passion alone is
not enough you need to have insatiable
curiosity i say passion is a spark but
the fuel is actually curiosity if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell